hey Thank You Cynthia and Connor for
organizing this and for inviting me it's
my great pleasure to speak in front of
such a great audience so I will talk
about a very cool topic in statistics
and machine learning sparse PCA and that
will describe the structure of the
problem and some exciting results done
privately and also i think i shall
mention some connections and the way i
think how this would fit into many
different methods inspect in
differential privacy and this is the
statistical part of this work is based
on my collaborators Vince woo who is in
the audience and actually he should take
a lot of credit for the statistical work
on this project and also with you here
and Carl our collaborators in Wisconsin
so this talk will have two parts so the
first part is the statistical part
sparse pca and finally I will talk about
the link between verse PCA and
differential privacy so the privacy part
is based on my own imagination and
immature thinking so you will find
anything in this part stupid or immature
blend me only not my collaborators okay
I make that clear alright so the
motivation for PCA is very simple right
i have high dimensional data iid and i
would like to do some linear dimension
reduction using principal components
analysis so the very basic introduction
to the general pca i have the covariance
matrix the underlying for the underlying
population and the PCA is simply given
by the eigenvalue decomposition for the
population covariance matrix and we have
lambdas the eigenvalues ordered in
decreasing rank and the eigenvectors the
VIS
so the optimal d-dimensional dimension
reduction in some sense is given by the
projection matrix corresponding to the
linear space spanned by the first d icon
vector and the optimal it says it
reduces the expected io2 distance
between the original vector and the
projected vector obviously we don't know
that the population covariance matrix
and we we estimated using the most
natural estimator sample average and we
calculate the counter parts of the the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors from the
sigma hat so and we just plug those in
as our estimators for the eigenvectors
and the projection matrix and these are
our standard estimators and they have
many different many nice properties in
the low dimensional regime where p is
fixed and you have a large sample right
now when when the number of parameters
or number of variables is large in the
sense that p over n converges to
something other than zero or even
infinity pca can be inconsistent in very
simple models so we would like to do
something else to take advantage of some
structure in the data and smarts pc is
one of them it offers simultaneous
dimension reduction and variable
selection and it has better statistical
properties we will see later and
obviously better interpretability so
interpretability means in the ordinary
pca if you have a large number of
variables so the linear projection may
involve many of them so you don't know
which ones are more important and which
ones are less important and it's marz
PCA automatically selects the important
ones so what you mean by sparsity in the
pc a problem right so here the sparsity
we want the Sebastian ocean to be
rotation invariant because there's
identifiability issue of the
eigenvectors we have eigenvalues with
multiplicity higher than
and then we cannot distinguish the
leading Adam vectors up to some rotation
so whatever i define or estimate shall
be rotation invariant because the really
good the real goal in pca is to find the
dimension reduction so we shall focus on
the projection matrix and we assume the
projection matrix has at most s long 0
rows and s is much smaller than p so the
interpretation is the projection you
want to do projection you only need to
look at those s variables so here is the
more detailed description of the
structure of the model so the Sigma can
be written in terms of the sum of two
matrices so the first part we call it
signal it has only a small s by s
nonzero block and the noise part
specific contains everything in the
corresponding to the remaining I
convectors right so what we want to do
is to estimate this projection matrix
which is sparse and when there is a gap
between the D and the D plus 1 second
values this decomposition is unique we
only want to separate the leading D and
the remaining so this is also a minimal
condition which I have just to uniquely
define the goal we're after so here is
the first theorem we developed just to
describe how sparsity interacts with
other model parameters like lambda d NP
in determining the hardness of the
problem so it says the optimal error
rate of estimating the projection matrix
in for venus norm
is this is a simple function of seven
numbers sdp n lambdas right and so it
depends on the diversity in the linear
manner and we have the D corresponding
to the parametric rate so you only if
you have an Oracle telling you those s
variables are two and we only have two s
times D so that's the low dimensional
part but here the log P comes from the
need to select the relevant variables so
it took us quite a few months to to
figure out this this some deep last log
P and also it's interesting to see the
lambda T plus one here that's another
tricky part because imagine lambda T
plus y is zero then you own the data
itself is indeed in P dimension so there
is zero error right and the this minimax
optimal rate is achieved by this varsity
constrained projection matrix and in the
PC a problem right even if we maximize
this trace of Sigma hat times pi over
all P dimensional projection matrices
that's the regular PCA and we add a
further sparsity constraint yep a few
sentences about the proof so everything
starts from the of the upper bounds the
lower bound is constructed to
construction using funnels method went
on the P part and the one that the T
part so the upper bound will cut we
start from curvature lemma which is very
cool it's different from Davis kahan and
when shall take most credit for for this
it says in the PC a problem so this guy
PI sub D is optimal and this guy our
estimator is suboptimal and each bounce
the gap in the objective function in
terms of the difference
right so this is the curvature of the PC
a problem and the the coefficients the
factor is determined by the icon tap so
intuitively very natural and indeed the
proof of this one is elementary but we
didn't find it in previous literature
and on the other hand we have the
estimator optimizing the objective
function using the estimated covariance
matrix and we combine these two we
entered this inequality this part is our
estimation error and this part is
actually can be bounded by an empirical
process because we we hope this matrix
is small it's the random mirror part
when the rest is some careful analysis
using empirical process and some other
techniques like the peeling thing yes
Sigma is the underlying true covariance
matrix so it's determined by the
distribution and the Sigma hatch is
estimated from the data ok so the
sandwich minus the expectation so it
corresponds to some form of empirical
process so as I said this serum gives
optimal dependence on the all these
seven parameters and it does not put any
additional structure assumptions on the
noise part so it doesn't have to be even
block diagonal and a popular assumption
is that it's spherical the noise is
spherical but the downside is the
proposed minimax estimator is np-hard to
compute so the next step we want to do
is to do some convex relaxation so here
is our convex formulation if you
attended the nips you probably have seen
the poster so we start from the standard
p
see a problem that's the maximizing the
trace between Sigma hat NZ that's just
the PCA part and we put a penalty
everyone penalty which you 01 because it
has this nice decomposed ability
property and what see what's really
interesting is the the constraint set
right remember we used to assume that
the Z shall be picked from the set of
all three dimensional projection
matrices but that city is not convex the
tightest convex of D dimensional
projection matrices this one so Z shall
be symmetric and positive definite with
all I can value between 0 and 1 and the
trace is d so it can be shown actually
we didn't show this we found this
resulting in the literature this is the
convex of all the dimension projection
and discord event hope named after the
mathematician ki fan this problem is
convex and we think it's the tightest
convex relaxation for PC a problem with
varsity and it can be solved using
standard methods like a dmm it's really
fast and and convenient yes one moment
of Z is just ok treating Z as a vector
so what can we say about this method
when the the penalty term the row is
chosen sorry I've made a typo this
should be log P is proportional to
square root of log p or n then the
Frobenius norm error of the output of
FPS satisfies this so it's it need
differs from the minimax raised in terms
of s square and we don't have that D
plus log P here so roughly speaking this
where there is off by a roughly by a
factor of s and and we we conjectured
you cannot substantially improve this
dependence for polynomial time
algorithms based on the inside provided
by the work by Brazilian regulate
earlier they said if you are doing
hypothesis testing then polynomial time
algorithms cannot distinguish like at
the level of when s is beyond this range
assuming that the planted click problem
is hard when this is smaller than square
root n so that's true let's established
for the testing problem and we think it
shouldn't be too different in the
estimation problem and the proof is very
short actually this is the ho proof we
extend the curvature lemma to the fan
hope this is also due to winds and we
use the same trick now we have the
curvature lame apart and the empirical
process part and the penalty part and we
we don't do very hardcore analysis on
the empirical process anymore because we
don't know too much about the Hat Z so
then we we use the fact that we have a
error one penalty and it dominates the
every entry in that error matrix so we
up with something very simple and the
the following analysis in standard using
triangle inequality and cauchy-schwarz
well so that's cool and we have just one
more question we want to do variable
selection right we don't know how sparse
that FPS solution will give us and even
at the ideal choice of of penalty
parameter so we hope so basically
everything is so similar to the lasso
right and I think maybe we can do
something similar in variable selection
and the problem the variable selection
problem 40 D equals 1 is analyzed in a
simplified assumption by a minion ring
right a few years ago so our result will
focus on that the fan hope so we were
able to do two things we first we we are
able to remove a common assumption so
which has been always there in in
previous work on variable selection in
pca so the diagonal part of the noise
matrix does not no longer has to be zero
it just needs to be bounded by something
but it does not have to be zero so we
remove this block diagonal assumption
and we were able to do for general value
of D so that's the the result the FPS
correctly select the relevant variables
when these four conditions holds because
we're doing more and more so we have
more and more assumptions the sample
complexity which is similar to previous
result and the incoherence right
remember in the LA so we want some
incoherent to limit the dependence
between the noise and the relevant
variable and here it is it basically
says
I have the covariance matrix that's the
signal block and the big noise block and
this block they're the same right and
this block is gamma 2 1 and it describes
the correlation between the signal
variable and the noise variable and what
I need is each row has bounded l2 norm
and the bound is proportional to 1 over
s and also we need signals raise the
minimum diagonal entry of the the
nonzero part of the projection matrix is
at least this large and also the tuning
parameter is ok right and one remark is
that the information theoretic lower
bound developed by amini and green
righties and at least p at least s times
log p so there's also a factor of Azoff
and it's also an open question if this
can be removed and in a polynomial time
algorithm and I just hide all the
constants or all the eigenvalues
included the constants right so the key
ingredients of this proof also so
they're really made the important part
is we only need the the Infinity norm of
the error that means the entry wise the
Infinity norm of the error matrix to be
small and it used strong duality and KKT
condition curvature lame again and
standard linear algebra linear algebra
and the perturbation theory all right so
it's a little bit more involved and
don't have enough time to go through it
now so that's the statistics part I want
to talk about differential privacy
especially for the FPS algorithm so
starting from now any mistake is on me
the analysis of FPS only needs to
satisfy the entry wise error bound right
what we really need is just the the
entry y0 band is on the order of
stewards of lockup Iran and in the
sample covariance matrix case this is
this follows from Bernstein and the
Union bound so the the first idea i had
to do differentially private FPS is to
further add entry wise perturbations on
the sample covariance matrix on the
order of square root log p or n if we
can do that then we're good okay the
first step Laplace noise it doesn't work
anymore at least in the high dimension
case so the goal is I want to release
the covariance sample covariance with
improvised accuracy screw to lock Peoria
and for simplicity assume that it is
bounded with zero mean if I do this the
improvised double double exponential
then the entry the the noise should be
of order P Square over and because I
have peace will increase I change one
roll of the data I change every entry at
the same time so this is a very naive
idea and we know it's not going to be
the best one so a further step forward
if we realize every entry of the
covariance matrix sample covariance
matrix is just a sample average and in
the in the computer computer science
literature it's called counting query
they are bounded and it is just sample
average so they're counting queries and
then if I use a result I'm
differentially private counting query
release and this is the best one I know
about maybe you can tell me you know
better once and I I would be able to
reduce the entry wise error rate to this
but a dump a potential downside is this
theory developed in that paper applies
to discrete space and what I need here
is
on continuous space but if my data is
really discreet and bounded then the
pseudo pie so I'm curious if one can
remove that extra log P to the to the
one force if we can do that then is
almost match the best results in
non-profit analysis well so the nice
thing I liked about the pc a problem is
you can attack it from different angle
that the structure is so nice the other
method is to use the stability test
right the perturbation stability in a
paper by Adam and ever deep so we want
to test how how stable the variable
selection result is right so I just
asked how many points I need to move in
my data set to obtain a different
variable selection result if that answer
is large enough then I proceeded with
the variable selection so i'm working on
much similar problem then things should
be should be much easier there and this
is applied to LA so again this is
motivated in partially by the similarity
we have observed so far between the
sparse pc and there are so so you can't
do it for the lasso then probably for
pca and the plan is we we do the model
selection first in DP and we just
released that small corner using another
DP procedure the rest is 0 but the
challenge is in the the query itself is
incentive but may be hard to compute and
my intuition on this I didn't write it
down because it's probably not true it
should be easier for pca because pc is
not an inverse problem so we don't need
to do the XX transpose inverse in pca pc
everything in pc is just sample average
so i expect the query is easier to find
in pca
and they're the third method if I just
write this in in the matrix form then
it's just it's not least not sample
average in more about matrix product and
every entry in the sample covariance
measures the covariance or correlation
or somehow in some sense the similarity
between the variables not the
individuals but it doesn't matter we can
switch the row between the variables and
the individuals and this is no one by
these two groups the papers of here at
about the same time Johnston
lindenstraße transformed like basically
you multiply the matrix by a random
matrix with iit calcium then the
pairwise similarity is roughly preserved
and at the same time you almost
automatically have differential privacy
so the idea is to use sample covariance
of perturbed version so our time X
optionally plus and an addition noise
matrix and then we just go from there so
the challenge you would beat you to
develop a good band so how for the
purpose of PCA right we only need the
entry wise error so how do we optimize
shoes are or Delta so that is the why is
that group as accurate as possible so my
hope is and I think it's true in in the
regime the FPS every works with the
solution should be very stable and we
shall be able to do all these but the
problem is which one shall I choose
which method is most suitable for this
sparse pc a problem and that's like I'm
actually a statistic and the user of
differential privacy so I need some help
to choose the right product so the final
message pc a sparse pc a very
interesting from a lots of good
structure so that should be the favorite
toy for theorists and the current
analysis
in quite a few frameworks of DP and
there are some some technique I'm
particularly interested in the accurate
release of peace we're related because
the the interests of covariance matrix
they are not independent they're they're
related hitting a freaky way Counting
craters in continuous space and the BDT
test for pc and then maybe if we found
find some structure and we can
generalize it to more general settings
and private Johnson Lyndon Strauss for
the PC a problem and even a DP ad mm I
really don't have any idea on this but
if we can do that that'll be really
really cool so all right I'm two minutes
overtime so that's thank you for
attention alternating Direction method
of multipliers it's a class of convex of
him optimization algorithm so it's very
cool for for problem where you have
multiple constraints so here we have the
fan hope and the l1 ball so it's hard to
find out the intersection between these
two by 380mm gives you like some quick
way for initial convergence
differentially private version of a DMM
so that means I I have an input to a dmm
and for any generic input and generic
ADM method can I to and say the dust the
step size in lady mm in the differential
private way so that the output is
automatically differentially private
well assuming of course changing one
data point only changes the input the
input structure in a simple manner right
but you can do a differentially private
stochastic gradient descent right that's
another class of of optimization method
so enjoy cook with Cynthia alienability
made some improvements on the first
approach and I talked about it tomorrow
so i think tomorrow actually yeah okay
so you can look at the video is very
good boy this is the normalization
issues so he was he was bounding just
the l infinity norm of the raw data
right whereas you guys found the old to
norm of the rod of the United panels so
he's balding head to norm of X I didn't
he say I thought that the assumption was
just that they were entry the entries of
the excise were the entry of the sample
covariance it's not the excise himself
so it's actually a collection of
counting query yet anyway I guess it
depends on how things are normalized
right however
so your assumption is that each X I is
mean zero norm at most one not normally
most much the every entry is that most
of you probably do so the knowledge that
will probably save a thousand p video ok
ok thanks